a much discussed new article in the
Atlantic raises a huge question is
marriage all it's made out to be
Ray Romano made his case for marriage on
his long-running sitcom but in the
Atlantic Mandy Len Catrin offers a
different take her article is called
what you lose when you gain a spouse she
says marriage can weaken other social
ties with friends and family leading to
feelings of loneliness more than 1
million people have read the piece on
the magazine's website
Mandy led Kent Lynn Katrin joins us now
Mandy good morning you're now getting
emails from people asking you for
marriage advice well what do you tell
them you know I don't necessarily feel
comfortable getting giving people advice
but I do know but I do think we we tend
to think that marriage isn't the right
way to live your life and the best way
to live your life and I want it to push
back against that and I wanted to
suggest that while there are many
benefits there are also some costs and I
don't think we talk about those costs
barrios so what are the costs well so
one of the things that I came across in
the research and the thing that really
surprised me is that marriage can be
really socially alienating and they've
done this study and basically they've
looked across different demographic
groups they've controlled for
socioeconomic status race all these
different things and they find that
people who are married and in particular
people who are married without children
tend to have fewer social ties than
those who are married and that manifests
and lots of ways like they have fewer
friends they're less likely to care for
aging parents they're less likely to ask
for help from their neighbors or offer
help in return so I thought that was
important are you married I am NOT okay
are you in a relationship I am okay yeah
long-standing yeah we've been together
about five years because I think people
were thinking so what are your
qualifications but the fact that you're
in a relationship means that you can
speak to this issue because when you
said marriage can make people lonely I
think you can be lonely if you're in a
bad marriage I don't know too many
people who are in a good marriage that
feel lonely doesn't that matter the type
of marriage that you're in it definitely
matters yeah like I would even consider
I would say my own relationship is a
really important part of my life it's
very happy yeah I feel deeply invested
in it and yet one of the things I
noticed when my partner moved in with me
is that suddenly I got fewer invitations
like people yeah less often when they
asked me to hang out they asked both of
us and I felt a real loss of those
relationships that I had cultivated
while I was single
well then cuz they probably think that
you're busy you're still you I love that
in the article you said love is the
marrow of life and that sometimes we
sort of we you know we sometimes often
people attempt to funnel it into the
narrow channels prescribed by marriage
in the nuclear family yeah thing there's
many different kinds of love is what I
hear you saying essentially what I argue
in the article and what and what I feel
really strongly about is you know it's
clear that only a relatively small
percentage of people are married and of
those people relatively small percentage
like I think it's roughly about half of
people over age 18 are married and then
a certain percentage of those are gonna
be happily married and you know there
are lots of people who aren't married
for whatever reason it's not working for
them but they have really important
forms of intimacy in their lives and we
don't we don't celebrate those or
support those in the same way that we
support marriage I think it's a really
thought-provoking article you're getting
a lot of Katherine thanks so much for
being with us